you just made me think if there's times
you go out and people say what are you
doing and you're like i work for
fandango it's nice to be able to
kind of just have that in your back
pocket i work for fandango
yeah man this is 1934. gangsters
submachine guns and you put cowboys on
bunny and clyde
texas rangers all right so this is a
project that's been in development
for many years and i think it's kind of
badass that
paul newman and robert redford
originally were going to be in these
roles is that something you guys ever
thought about maybe made you smile a
little bit
we always thought we'd do better no i'm
not no
it's pretty cool is that really true
yeah it is true
i heard their name and ten years ago it
came to me and then
then it drifted off and then it circled
back um so
yeah listen a lot of movies i've had
good luck with movies that take a long
time to get made yeah
you know why because they they they ring
a little different
people are unsure studios are unsure
they're not
what's happening at the moment at the
time and uh
so so a lot a lot of a lot of the great
movies have
languished yeah you know i think one of
the things i find so fascinating about
this film is you guys actually
shot in the specific location where
bonnie and clyde were
were killed and what was that day like
for you guys was it did it amplify
the experience did it amplify your
performances in any way
yeah i think we both had a real strong
reaction to it because as an actor
you're using a lot of imagination but
when you're right on the spot
with the the final moment
bonnie and clyde's final breaths were
taken
uh yeah it really kind of it amplifies
yeah i think amplified is a really good
word you know
you understood kind of the native
strategy behind all of it
and you under understood that at the
moment that
car that they'd finally been waiting for
was coming
it was going to go down in about 40
seconds
you know frank hamer was a guy that did
not like to talk about
sort of his work um what did you look to
to sort of
inform your performance of him well none
of the they made a pact
that none of them would talk after that
because
killing a woman was a hard thing to kind
of
deal with and they were they were guys
that
didn't think of themselves heroically uh
i think that they just they really just
did their job but when it was over they
all kind of agreed let's not talk about
this
you know and that's why versions came
out you know and all
probably probably the worst versions
came out when relatives started to get
jealous thinking that their
their uh father who was involved in this
was being slighted somehow yeah
but i think the men themselves had a
bond uh they understood what it was they
were doing
you know considering that you know that
that those circumstances did you feel
sort of a greater duty to sort of tell
this story as
honest and authentic as you could yeah
i think that big part of that uh you
know
conscientiousness about the the facts of
the story
was involved in this you know it's still
really i think
wonderfully entertaining if i may say
but uh
but i think you know getting the facts
right was kind of
important you know you've played uh the
psychopathic killer in the past in a
movie that was
in many ways inspired by bonnie and
clyde does playing a psychopath inform
your performance of a man who's on the
hunt for one at all
uh
sure
[Laughter]
tell him what he wants to hear he's
after
[Laughter]
this has to end
they've committed dozens of armed
robberies
and several cold-blooded murders
what do you plan to do about bonnie and
clyde we will capture them
write that down and underline it twice i
think a lot of people are going to watch
this movie and have no idea
that texas had a female governor i
didn't in the 1920s
ah no me me neither how cool is that
it's very cool
and my mom was born in 1907. i think she
would have made a great governor of
texas
or tennessee so um the fact that in
those days that
you know jobs were limited for women
especially
that she rose to power is nothing short
of a miracle
i thought it was so interesting when i
was reading about her that she kind of
used her husband who was a former
governor
and sort of saying yeah i'm just gonna
kind of do his work you know to kind of
convince people to to one governor for
the price
yeah two exactly two two governors for
the price of one
uh and she's so interesting and
fascinating we don't get a ton of her in
this film but like in reading about her
and learning about her what's something
unique
uh about her life maybe that we don't
see
in the movie well i didn't know that she
loathed
the texas rangers and that she was
actually in the process with her
ferguson men
who were much more modern with their
cars and machine guns and their
walkie-talkies and
and so forth and and uh hoover
you know came and created the fbi the
year after they got bonnie and clyde
so the country was really changing and
she looked at these guys as totally
antiquated
in fact when in the couple of years that
she wasn't in power in between her two
terms
he retired he kept his commission hamer
did but
he loathed her she just felt that they
were antiquated she didn't appreciate
the fact that they could track she just
thought that was like you know
1800s crap and
plus the fact that they just did what
they wanted to do without her being able
to control them
yeah but i mean sometimes it's the old
school
kind of traits totally lead to it well
her guys didn't have the ability to do
that
you know they didn't know what they were
doing why do you feel like this is
an important story maybe to tell right
now well i think it's a wonderful
comment on celebrity
yeah isn't it i mean and it it took
place in the depression
i mean we're not technically in a
depression but they're people that are
hurting and i think
um i know i do it's like if if i don't
want to pay any attention to the news
because it's just overwhelming i sit in
front of the tv and watch
netflix or amazon or it's like what is
what's on i've got to escape for a while
and i think that that's very much part
of that you know and they
they were such icons and they i think
people back then looked at him as robin
hood and they were their heroes they
were glamorous she was
having an illicit affair you know it was
in all the magazines and
um it was just it was huge i think it's
wild thousands of people
20 000 people went to her funeral 10
15 went to his which is just wild well
even after they were shot
people were already clamoring around the
car and trying to cut pieces of her
bloody hair and there was a guy
trying to cut his trigger finger off and
crazy crazy stuff
i thought it was so interesting that
they actually shot
that scene when they when they finally
catch bonnie and clyde
and and wind up killing them they shot
that in the same spot
i know wasn't that something that's i
didn't know that until last night when
john lee said that
and i know woody and kevin were kind of
like
they knew of course and it just added an
extra
feeling of oh my god you know this is
real this really happened
one of the things i love about your
career is you play a lot of a lot of
strong women a lot of women that sort of
know what they want
know how to get it you know what
attracts you to that and do you
uh pull from them throughout your life
when you know throughout your career
when you're playing a new character do
you pull sort of traits or
or dip back into your past at all and
say i liked how i played this character
i'm gonna maybe
do that a little bit with this one um
that's an interesting question i i guess
i i guess i do
you know that it's it's interesting that
there's
for me and i think it's probably true of
other actors that when you get a role
it's like already inside you you start
percolating
and you start bringing as you say
different aspect oh that reminds me and
i
daniel day lewis gave a class at
juilliard recently
and a friend of mine that i was working
with aaron moten he had a friend
there at juilliard and they were like
tell me what he's saying tell me what
he's saying you know
and one of the first things he said was
your first ideas
just write them down don't do anything
about it yet because you don't know
enough
so there is a lot of um jessica tandy
used to call it your kitchen work
you know and that you weren't ready yet
to
serve uh the soup so to speak but
um yeah it's almost on a molecular level
you know you start
you know getting ideas oh in the middle
of a conversation you said wait a minute
wait a minute and now with your phone
you can just go
you know and get it on there on your
notepad and then start thinking about it
in different ways
this has gone far enough i'm going to
take them down
what a fine idea
who are you fellas i was one of the bad
guys
i saw the devil you know everybody knows
the story of bonnie and clyde why do you
think
this was an important story to tell
about the apprehension of bonnie and
clyde and
why right now well i mean i first heard
the script 13 years ago when john fusco
and casey silver sent it to me to gauge
my interest in directing and i thought
my first thought was oh bonnie and clyde
you know i love pins movie i've seen
other movies why
why do this and when i read it i
realized it was
switching the camera over you know to
the the texas rangers that came out of
retirement
and i thought the themes involved were
contemporary then i think they're
contemporary now
um but i was just drawn into the the
idea of these two men who have a
terrible gift
you know one of the things i love about
the film is that uh you know bonnie and
clyde they're
celebrities people who you know kind of
adored them i mean thousands of people
showed up at their funeral but you don't
see them really you know you keep them
shadowy uh
yeah and why did you make that choice to
sort of not show us bonnie
well first it was john's conceit um
to to i think he says in there you never
quite get a good look at them and then
so when i started thinking about it i
wanted to shoot them
in a non-naturalistic way i wanted it to
be like a graphic novel
where the colors pop and the frames are
interesting and the cars are sexy and
shiny
so that hopefully we as a viewer would
fall
under the sway of the mythology of
bonnie and clyde and
think of them as bigger than life and
romanticize them so
at the end in the ambush when they are
then shot in a natural way we realized
they're
they're skinny kids and talk about you
know
you shot some of this stuff in the
actual locations
i believe uh including that death scene
you know you did you went to the to the
actual
spot in the road where that happened we
did we first were looking at it just for
a historical basis so that we could find
another location that
kind of seemed to fit but when you got
there you looked at the way the road
undulated and how the car would appear
around
you know cops of trees and the
the length of time it would take for the
car to get to the spot and you can just
feel the roller coaster ride of going
click
click click and then and i thought wow
this is going to be hard to find and
then casey silver our brilliant producer
said
well what if we just shot it here and
you know it was like
the eureka moment and we did and it was
eerie and creepy
and i don't know it was it was it was
the right decision for sure but it was
creepy
i imagine people was there kind of did
you feel like a certain vibe did
everybody
there feel sort of this weirdness and
this oddness of that moment
they did and i think especially the
actors who are you know are holding the
guns and they're going to be firing at
this car
that's coming coming coming coming
coming i think
they got amped up probably not unlike
the posse that was there
in 1934. you know frank hamer
notoriously
didn't ever want to talk about himself
there's a moment in the
where somebody tries to interview him
and he kind of you know woody harrison's
character you should you should be
ashamed of yourself
yeah you know so is that hard to sort of
find out who this guy was
when he notoriously did not ever want to
talk about who he was
well the posse made a pact you know
among themselves that
we're not going to talk about this yeah
there's there's there's nothing good
that comes from talking about a horrible
death
and no one should ever make a dime off
of it
and that was he was old school that way
there have been many books written
about frank hamer and about the texas
rangers and about bonnie and clyde
um and you know you can do a search of
history and you could write you could
make 10 movies about frank hamer's life
there's a recent book that came out
that's
about frank hamer and it's just
fascinating
now if people watch this film and they
walk away and they they want to learn
more about the rangers they want to
maybe learn more about hamer what would
you recommend sort of as a complimentary
to this film to sort of go experience
after you watch it oh gosh well i would
i would say the
the first thing people tell me is they
they go to they go to google immediately
and start pulling up every document they
can to find out is this true did this
happen
did texas really have a female governor
in 1934.
so they start start with your internet
search and then there are many many
really good books and lots of
photography on the internet as well that
you can look at
you